engineer was so full podcast with
Rodrigo Toria yeah man we're back back
in action what's happening dawg
I don't know mavin doing much I've been
sleeping late waking up early
lucky paranoid rifle you know merry mood
to a new place guy get to you got you
got when you move to a new place I don't
care you're moving to a mansion an
apartment a cardboard or you live in the
streets you got to get to go you got to
get used to the noises that that creep
you out so you give me a clue mate it
right now yeah my like I hear like the
other night I was laying down bro at
2:00 in the morning I thought I thought
I felt like somebody running on the roof
how do you raccoon fool it was heavy man
probably a raccoon oh okay okay I got me
a mic I never been I never I've never
been in the house uh-huh I just know
what live in an apartment man I know
when the people running upstairs so I'm
getting punched you know or someone
using a toilet over here like a plumbing
the water draining all the way down to
my room here the pipes but now man I
hear the car I thought that somebody was
rolling on top of the roof I went out I
turn the lights on went outside nothing
bro the shot go away to 5:00 in the
morning boom yeah so the light we're not
then I thought safe
oh did you call the cops right then the
cops will come right away you look home
right away right Daniel
so when outside to go look
nothing messy not even go outside but I
wouldn't sleep looking at the window we
have we have our an alarm system you
know haha then I'm my paranoid cuz I'm
watching um I'm watching this this show
and a ID channel called murder calls
call 9-1-1 call room looks like my house
dog oh yeah
but I noticed that in murder cause it
was a family member like somebody you
invited to a barbecue let them over come
back later around 8:00 so [ __ ] said no
more barbecues and then usually inside
jostle with everything yeah usually a
family it's always a family member so
they have to resent me some
but you haven't murdered the ID channel
has everything you could they go with
murder
they have murder cause so June 9 1 1
calls then they have bomb vows that
people got married then they kill the
husband or the wife killed somebody
god damn deadly vows deadly vows for
what the power fatal balls and for what
the insurance money
whatever was he might meet to buy a new
man I get married I'm his chick I saw
you know she killed her husband right so
she was fooling around with somebody and
she kept checking back to see men he got
penny Sherman again all to make sure she
are he already did the paperwork for the
guy every week she kept shaking most
every day
then I his job they had a they have that
a little one a little mason jars with
with his face uh-huh
and I his player customers he putting
money in it that busy go everyday
collective up oh my god she's taking
that to fool everything any other little
things of evidence she left behind on
the Cotterell she live a full record
block did dummy dog
I guess she's never killed any ball also
she she asked two people had bars and
they want to kill him for her and they
testify to like who the bar back like
there's no a picture and a bar a good
said man what's your name again
Berman would you do for a living ology
to comedy end I ran a bike with my with
my bird oh man amen you know anybody
want to kill somebody
am I going somebody [ __ ] I'll do it bro
and she was like she wanted like to pay
like but she was wet they ride her album
because she didn't have all the money
first of all she said after I get the
ensuring we know what we're all get paid
ain't nobody gonna kill somebody for no
money on credit [ __ ] dude how cool are
you with that person dog I probably will
if I hate oh hey LEM oh [ __ ] about
people boy somebody might do that not
myself you know what I don't want to
kill nobody I wanted to live in pain
their whole life Oh suffer
did I just torture the [ __ ] out of
somebody dog dude say I tell you the
story about some guy that killed reading
an apartment from someone I know and he
want to move out of that fool came over
right and you know he would hang our
landlord hanging out right but Sabu
found out they put a private collection
of Bob comic books the landlord yeah so
they were party cuz he showed him one
senator party a check it out they can't
shut I win the gold dog that's what a
vacation I put came back got the key
brewing took the collection done are you
serious so he couldn't prove it down
so though his house the only landlords
house we get tagged you know your donkey
still gets along so this was so drilling
holes all over house grew and pouring
water and I'm gonna cover him up which
is [ __ ] up the wall given that much
little [ __ ] he was really hose pouring
water in it and then patching it up
broke and moldy ass all over the house
dogs black mold and they left and he
never got the comic books better bro
dude he would have [ __ ] up that force
was hardcore but the Fox laughs or some
Python bro is didn't collect nobody oh
my god so were so full shot out to
everybody from the podcast shout out to
that guy from Australia who somewhere
yeah man I did a big show on Thursday
night
The Comedy Store so how's that it was
good bro Harley Williams Bryan Callen
and the fighter
Brendan Schaub bred in Shaba yada Fuu
you could tell her food a bunkie to
fight broke his [ __ ] ear look like
they bit it off and then they sewed it
back on a cauliflower ear
yeah brulee talk a lot of foods there a
lot of heals
I know foods who are not professional
fighter who live here like that
professional street fighters dog who has
to wear with that I just wear a Dodger
Stadium here we'll let that bro and I
were talking now but who's gonna make
him smaller bro so he cut himself who
makes up stories I said he'll cut
reading oh yeah so he performed Chris
D'Elia
okay and
Joe Rogan on the powerful Joe Rogan
hell yeah but I went up after him oh
hell yeah and I'm sound better to
believe Ben Gleib and clean and Josh was
the return oh yeah man it's our 30th
date I guess 30 I don't know I'm making
[ __ ] oh god damn fool what it was good
show man you know it was awesome show
the I like it was sold out first of all
the main room yeah sold out I went up
there did my um I went over the 19
minutes to the 15 so good nobody station
I mean I did my new stuff let the stuff
that's coming like that's coming out on
a special September 30 and HBO not
desktop I'll try on some newer stuff
darker stuff you know okay but I saw Joe
roll I mean I stood right uh I don't
want to bug people so I just when people
comedian were coming in I was saying
hello haven't seen Chris D'Elia and
forever say hello
although food Bryan Callen Joe Rogan bro
that foreign body is healing by clean up
hey man I like to help you my podcast
oh hell yeah so I might get I might be a
JRE oh that's what's up for so um who I
talked to here man now I invited some
guy from shoutout to lure 13 they won
best pre joint on that child's festival
damn was that it was a Victorville bro I
think what today was on yeah he was in
wrong we don't smoke the same bro they
took nothing no bro powerful as we were
13 won first place on pre roll joints uh
and he told me that it was 27
contestants and three or four or five of
them though we'd have pesticide bro well
see did I tell it I told you dude like
you notice when you smoke it that's
always welcome pesticide room yeah if we
kill the bug so doesn't kill your weed
so people stay away from Monsanto push
the [ __ ] watering that we with water
from Flint
yeah man so pesticide yeah well you're
supposed to use organic pesticide I know
it man you yourself remember that I wish
to go down right anywhere with her bio
power liches
but we will we'll meet somebody like
calm katanas that kid that was doing hi
cool and you know that one day you try
get rid of it we did not brought you to
450 instead of 50
yeah yeah something's wrong with it or
CC what's OBC British Columbia anything
it's just a common weed did it's a
common like good weed but it's so common
it's like low quality that everybody has
it full it looks like [ __ ] [ __ ] smells
like [ __ ] it is I mean it's good but
it's not that good it's not worth 50
bucks Nate bug forty huh [ __ ] that 25 if
you said 25 take me there
but it just it's not that good it gets
you so hot I mean you plateau after a
little bit so uh I'm the guy speedy from
Louie the 13 he showed up to the don't
know hell yeah I got that fool in and he
get he gave me a pack of the Lauria
pre-rolls the one that we're at the
chatter festival so Scott won those
violins bro so right away brush our
Rogen
I give that full one I fool it in the
back oh really
smoked in the back of the Comedy Store
and then I went up on stage and he
brought me up with manly that comedian
man he got me high as [ __ ] backstage
right now
powerful join powerful those tremendous
that it was a joint that made Joe Diaz
take his clothes off
[ __ ] combat boots the Cuba Negron so
it matter the good he brought me your
Metro tight you know real xx man one
looking funniest guy in the world
[ __ ] Andy so I've had that badass so I
took a crowd map got your row get high
with Louisa 13 hello everybody I'm happy
they saw who said I got new at 13 to so
full stood it by himself bro with red
eyes bro that's all you need when you
know he did their his I know buddy cuz I
look like he was crying before the show
looking like a demon like he was in a
zone by himself
Ramos is into a black couple happy dog I
said would you adopt this kid he was out
to church he followed everybody and then
that was me on the shoutout
yeah man so I did that gig it was fun I
start Shiva there rather than to achieve
others did I not that night I
soichiro there bro I gave him a joint -
I'm free bro and I gave one to Jason
rouse ah hell yeah idea and then I'm
it's funny because I had given that
guy's DVC the Comedy Store tour I'll
give the whole tour well the rooms are
at and that and back back but there's
more to the Comedy Store now that didn't
know about but there's no rooms remember
the room only two books were smoking
back and there was in the back when we
smoked that joint without that black
comedian for that his name yeah but we
went to the back member that one time
Eddie Murphy was there yeah we were in
the back smoking coming so we went to
the kitchen
we would have a little garden that was a
dirt that goes up yeah well they got
chairs there now bro couches or lounge
down yes they were light so there's a
light is [ __ ] kick back bro
it's no more like smoking but in the
back of a communist or and hiding like a
loser bro damn chairs Bri could network
or three many good said man and you have
an official coming out yeah what are you
doing here Jason trousers hanging out
bro we do enjoy so he'll tease and then
they achieve oh boy by the way because
George Brett achievable because he had a
little goat area and um he's a Chivo so
now fool take you to another spot that's
inside a bar bar that they were bar
instead of part for comedians right yes
and your friend and go in there and
there's already bro and it's like a
private bar for the other paid regulars
or could be in the show up with a
coked-out chick you know they want to
get her all [ __ ] up more coked out you
take her back there dog hell yeah
[ __ ] bad-ass and it's all plus it's a
good time to be a comedian bro oh yeah
I'm seriously man I imagine garbage
trying to invite me over in column for
spot coming for spots okay I don't know
man so weird everybody gets bumped but
no man
nobody did more than the allotted time
like those 15 minutes then when I went
over for three right but didn't go to 25
then the last year bro going over ten
minutes back in the day back in the day
[ __ ] no no the start turns on I mean
keep going
it means up it just got approved Oh
so I'll go back on Saturday night to the
Comedy Store and do the podcast [ __ ]
uber that [ __ ] over there right all the
way all the way took 30 minutes to get
there
quiet I run into [ __ ] um guess were
the baddest car there fufu Polly sure
what yeah
oh my god has a convertible classic car
bro green dog a Chevy Malibu bro
he comes in bro [ __ ] snapchatting all
the way into the comedy store cuz I
checked his timeline dog he goes brah
it's fun do his voice much give you some
things some clues and hints that he was
saying and you do his voice but first of
all there was no power in Silverlake so
I put in shower so he was complaining
the hotel door and a little musty
Braille in my Malibu
yeah so here that home state he can't
take a shower to get to doctor partly
closed no Chinese seat tonight buddy
so though no it was yeah buddy got no
lights bro story nah bro so still [ __ ]
it dude all musty just leaves did you
get to a comedy store Polly short and I
flew her field I stopped what I'm doing
here talking to somebody and I really
got Chinese soup nobody know what the
[ __ ] I'm talking about
XSI least soup chinese soup heyyy bunny
come here buddy
he focuses on his nap shot angry cause
me bro
Chinese soup there's also a chance for
funny how you been bro
we should have seen him bro complaining
all [ __ ] day or night then when it
gets home it's even darker dog still
dark when he go start the AC didn't go
watch her morning bro it was a hundred
it was 106 on Saturday dog God so I do a
podcast The Comedy Store podcast I don't
know when they release it but it's an
odd thing comedy was Eleanor Kerrigan
and Rick Ingram okay so I didn't think
about it - a little podcast with them
that Rick Ingram and Eleanor Kerrigan
they've been around when that when a
Comedy Store was dying out when it was
you know what was happening then they
were dying
out but then the only happening room was
Fat Tuesday rat rat and then it died out
again and then call him and see ya and
Joe Rogan had a little dispute you know
and and then I'm Joe Rogan laughs then
he came back but those two always been
there huh oh yeah they never were left
held on that back then when she should
be a waitress back Yeah right before I
start working with dice she's to date
dice right wouldn't she would dice
massage your shoulder something right
get the kink out Ellen oh yeah for those
of those days don't know that I used to
do like an hour dog out an hour easy
we used to work with a cloak I remember
I was telling you about getting bumped I
tell me we're all getting bumped by
Eddie Griffin but I'd like everybody
else who's pissed off
me I was like [ __ ] I get to see a freak
for ADA Griffin Show hell yeah and I
stood there bro night there's nothing he
would say it was like love that stuff
even [ __ ] comedy it was a lot of like
the journey
I love the journey here falling off the
chair um him talking about you know
pretty much stuff that I would normally
tell somebody when I'm drunk personally
like I'll [ __ ] this guy [ __ ]
Ernie G or [ __ ] the devil you know or
get really in deep inner thigh let's
just kind of [ __ ] that Eddie Griffin
would tell the audience but didn't know
what the [ __ ] he was talking about but I
did it's funny every time it would
finish his story he'll ask for a little
champagne
give me another Paul Mooney and that's
why one day he's wearing all white he
finished filming a movie or some [ __ ]
it was rusty or some [ __ ] were there for
three hours dog it's really when I'm
Eddie Griffin what I'm his type of our
bitterness it's different for my type of
bitterness back then he was that he was
in there man and I remember if we were
held in a podcast I will bring this
story up because it's true he was in the
bombed-out dog first of all because
Malcolm and Eddie was I was still on the
show I don't know if I was doing a show
over the reruns but I'm I guess through
some lawyers and all that um the whole
time that the song was playing Malcolm
and Eddie the theme song
Eddie Griffin helped write that [ __ ] so
he never got [ __ ] no credit so finally
you know he's fighting about to get
something
man he's [ __ ] Warner Bros and
holding out a five million
Samantha was that's what you like I
guess I don't notice why was comedian
that they could disarm work particles
I've been doing it for a longer time and
I didn't get like success in my 20s I
don't know buddy
I was out to get out to accept my 20 but
I see like um paint cook you know I'm
his brother doing his accounting and he
[ __ ] I'm taking half of the [ __ ] and
then like half brother or some [ __ ]
Hurley [ __ ] took like 14 million
right straight Jack deth will bear it
all over the country now he's out of
jail scooping up his cheese damn bro how
could you go I was talking about a band
like when people like don't pay the rent
or how can you goes five months six
months without paying the read and
expect to still be there I don't know I
think that's who that though okay what's
the law in California about missing rent
and you're gonna kick you out you get
the what in California with three days
three days and quit but it depends in LA
County I know you can at least extend it
like three months 90 days but I know
Riverside County they're more on like
the landlord side here in LA they're
more it's more like a renters there on
the renter's side but you know it's it's
different in every jurisdiction but yeah
I don't know what the [ __ ] a so I hung
out at the Comedy Store I write um I
wanted exciting bread was like brought
you back consider what yam a lot of
people there though the main show was
sold out good lineup
Joey was in the show because he wasn't
that big it's at a UFC fight Joe Diaz I
don't know the [ __ ] he was but I got to
hug all the comedians there I met that
comedian that um that was on the arm
rows battle frank casteel frankerz yeah
yeah this one fool okay well I'll tell
ya when we talked about I told him that
you and I talked about how they brought
him up all my daddy styling I don't know
Spanish or something yeah
fool here when I were talking he said
were worse than when we saw what the
[ __ ] happened you say they were worse
they would add all this [ __ ] but he
[ __ ] fought all that stuff but then
he said listen man you're gonna bring
out that stuff at least bring American
flag out too so to let him know cuz I
told you those rose petals I seen a
couple just they're like yeah man racial
you sure the way he said it was worse
than the stuff that that they got
deleted he had to fight to get some
stuff out just come on
and then um a lot of who his Trump joke
that he was throwing about Baron Trump
he had a shitload about didn't get
getting get here they don't want to put
him on now they're been killer of
quarters dog see that's the thing that
[ __ ] sucks do you laugh or scuba no
young fool
she will arm I don't know that Haman she
would they were on a lot of young comics
but he's not a paid regular I saw Byron
Byron Bowers okay he came here wedding
with Marcela yeah man
without the legs I ran into bread urns
bro
I'm through drew threw me off rifle my
focus chewing tobacco dog goddamn before
I was a loose tobacco deal on his chin
yeah i'ma see you later see a baseball
players it's a woman bro communist or a
spittoon god damn fool I shoot you back
like a shortstop now what happened but
we do too many shows in Florida but
everybody smoked cigars over a little
the [ __ ] who this tobacco share nomads
wedding though yeah Mexico today some
tube [ __ ] remember talking about my
being with that snuff stuff a little
sucks six-month thing [ __ ] that all
about I don't understand stuff man but
definitely I should go I could go a
little snuff right now
[ __ ] that I'm like [ __ ] smoke cigars a
brown let it go mad but those are
there's also a lot of comedian that war
going up that were there to you what I
it like you can't hang out there like
you can hang out all you can I don't
know or they you have to come in with a
comedian there's like rules now to go to
the comedy store we forward outside you
know out there but all you know outside
I feel okay okay okay yeah cuz to kick
in that one room I went in there one day
with Joe Diaz because I went with Joe
Diaz for the bar the red bar hair but um
you guys have a spot or you'll be a pain
trigger I have to have a spot a paid
regular you have to be a guest of a
comedian yeah he has to go in there with
you yeah it's like you can't chill like
the floors ruffian somebody regularly
yeah you know my name is on the walls in
the front though on the top added they
had a spot yeah but they thought I was
there they probably don't know you yet
or none of that [ __ ] you don't know me
they all like there were all cool man
that I met the gog my manager Richie I
used to hit well with Joey a theme you
steal you might recognize them he's to
hangover-free Soto
from the phrase hole of dignity Ritchie
18 easily looked Italian here blue eyes
let me have another guy and he said they
were pretty cool but when I said I
wanted to get a coffee now forward to go
get it okay so whoever that we did the
comedy the the with the podcast instant
comedy storing up and the basement guess
what a basement in another hidden gym
not to run out right when you walk in to
the left
yeah right there was a bathroom is yeah
they have the rules everybody know that
gate I didn't know that I went down
there one time with no he's Gonzalez
back in the days to get what chairs he
took me down there to see some old
checks like Chris Rock checks and all
this [ __ ] Eddie Griffin check center
that they never catch the number took oh
[ __ ] I was shipped out on that one night
to go pick up my please checked by the
way are maybe listening their check that
are given by the money either by the
improv with a Comedy Store or the last
factory you know checks that you get at
the end of the week when you do a
shoulder Monday through Friday or
Saturday right money through
usually they pay up well if you're
paying regular is Monday is Tuesday
through Saturday you get paid and you
don't get paid funny short I think well
I don't know I don't know I don't know
how it works but every week there's
checks and I remember picking up my six
dollar check both dirty dollar check
from [ __ ] The Laugh Factory and I see
a check there for [ __ ] Bob Saget to
grad I know or or I see a check on start
another comedian shared for 600 bucks
$400 800 $300 $200 all expired
damn me and then me and Paula Bell other
trying to get 25 bucks yeah dude then
she's come in handy
[ __ ] yeah my man I go get one for the
Laugh Factory full at Amory drove to
Chicago to pick up that check that he
said he drove the Cancun no the last
fact she had a check there for him and
their fool where to go pick it up in
Chicago 30 bucks
damn my honey go pick up a rebellion
yeah emailed it to him like what's two
months up to the spot or some shitty
said I remember the Emperor gave me a
check for $15 for doing a set and they
took taxes out bro
oh my
- it was up $10 well it's like ants
kimchi on those taxes dogs I got loads
of that data sign it off to the waitress
like Christmas eka food crystal and Sega
had a check for $30 29 5 2013 at the
Laugh Factory and I'm he worried a bunch
of drinks and he was trying to write
outside to check off to lease I think
for all the time my calves ran out
without pain Lee said she cut that food
to eat a month later clap at me with the
same receipt they made you pay for it
huh mica drink [ __ ] up Jamie they care
about you pay yeah dude I mean that
should be on the club though for scarves
does that that's [ __ ] put it on the
way Tristan playing I'm gonna do that
one babel [ __ ] up their walk out of
there sorry next time fool what's up I'm
changing dog why would that people got
me a Costco card and never had one of my
life now you're binding bowtie only bid
there warrants in my life
they got being aware there was gay bro
all I went to a gay bro once and then
organic but but that's a good I might be
a bro we're noms
so she cost us all them both I didn't
know that right cuz I'm used to just
Walmart or Target or Sears but I didn't
look now I know where my Dean got his
food at I want everyone to Marty's house
and that's a big horse 20 pound of
chorizo dogs for last month oh my god
dude myself like why buy jewelry so you
know for the market it's a little pack
you know the little a to be the little
tiny pack with to Marty Marino's
apartment that [ __ ] had a size
of chorizo precise or focused a lot of
the size of [ __ ] baloney bro yeah
take it out back and shoot it on the
professional shoulder Brooke just gonna
shoot a professional hard to Leon Leon
the professional yeah yeah we're so fool
you got sound Triple E here in the
okay enjoy yourself I don't got Sam
Tripoli in the house I don't know what
the [ __ ] going on with that head but
here God Chuck I'm a little lit good
night I don't know what I'm [ __ ] get
out here to get the [ __ ] rules you
know I'm saying ha ha I'm thinking about
dyeing my ball hair and [ __ ] you I'm
saying everybody who use it ha ha
not anymore you know I'm saying nothing
yes are you happy to be here dude
are you guys are twenty five minutes
into this 29th of it yeah well I thought
what time to start odds noon this night
did we you know did a little intro
person ok little intro man we're talking
about how I'm a bit too a comedy story
in Eon stays on day since Tom before
tommy was there you haven't been there
forever
well I've been there like to do like a
showcase when I were with another with
maverick yeah 1111 yeah and another
comedian that we're maverick will be
there Dante me and Jay London what an
interesting group yeah so they never got
rid of us I went to our main Asian left
to become the comedy lead the lead agent
and Adam Abrams they dumped the dog all
he took the only active he took with the
actor from well that [ __ ] say by the
Bell who screech no mr. Beldon oh snap
he too with the Bell what a great story
dumped us all bro damn mr. belyeu
yeah probably would do that movie that
showcase dog it'll be the I remember
that be unsung heroes of comedy bro
it'll be me Jay Davis he tell you don t
je London huh mr. Belvedere dog no no
nobody was so old nobody didn't that
dinner
the [ __ ] cook this got actor took
comedian it was that they could the
actor from the office space
hey Kiki hey guys you wanna order couple
guys he was though she's here with their
shooters here hear them you work this
anyways yeah
you hear a flare bro it off the streets
dude you just think about all the crazy
gigs used to do
and like how you're just trying to get
something going and you just put
yourself in like the worst positions
possible
some people think having a bad manager
is better than having no manager I
completely disagree that I agree to
member I know you thinking about man
that that lands nobody was there I was
thinking right now [ __ ] yeah I'm [ __ ]
nervous for nothing yeah no I want to
take back I want to take back my
nervousness I want to take back those be
prepared for that show
picking up my clothes sided Time Machine
just go back get away [ __ ] up being
nervous dog weird about [ __ ] when you're
not even supposed to hunt up our agent
I'm Jay Shaq nourish actor all he did
was took everybody they got past a
carpet though last cover Stanley Z know
I'm a [ __ ] manatees guys yeah hold on
dude now is he still going yeah he's a
lead agent at Abrams artist yeah I mean
I would totally remember all those each
other take a look now but I'm that guy I
told you connected me to him yeah he's
running I would not used to be able to
do boys to color my [ __ ] seven times
nothing I will go in there bro to
recited again for another year of no
work right Hey I felt bad and you know
that there's that I'm gonna be a list
with agency again and I have not put in
nothing I'm not putting no money towards
them and I see all the young their main
thing was child actors by the way oh
that's not so good when their main thing
isn't what you are yeah I use child
actors cuz I remember going to the cuz
every Christian they have a party right
and everybody's happy bro happy I'm
doing hanging out with a comedian going
I can't you know the ones that keep this
company afloat yeah they were sticky
this ship parts are little kids excited
very happy bro
the Nickelodeon show they're happy to be
around a bar yeah that's do the chaos of
your early career
I was happy to let the lady in this time
I had a [ __ ] actually an invitation
to go in
we're just looking pot instead of going
and it was like man but you believed it
at that time brown cool them I know
comments right now young comics much
arezzo so it'll be exciting but also
it's like so interesting how like we
believe all suits are created equal
like they're all equally smart and
they're all equally good-looking they
all equally work the same way and it's
not true you there's just like there's
bad comics there's bad suits who have no
clue what the [ __ ] they're doing I had a
friend of mine with a major talent
contest her manager did nothing with it
like nothing and you're just like if she
had been with a different person at that
time who knows where her career could
have been he literally is a crapshoot
and that's why there's like certain guys
like you're really hoping to get with
because they have a track record of
getting [ __ ] done but then you've tried
to get these people like I always made
the mistake of signing with friends that
was the worst thing like my there's like
some waitress decide you want to be a
manager if you're like heck and I've had
at you you were like how somebody loves
me right itself erm a tional you know
and then you're like I did work out a
year later wonder why let's play about
what I was manager when I was like well
that's when I won left AMA standing like
I had like I was beat everybody bro
everybody has a little piece everybody
that wasn't looking at me twice before
right everybody that I put a score drugs
for report you know and um and those are
people that want to take a meeting who I
knew bro and I'm staying [ __ ] you look
at me yo ass nice are you a double in
many years yeah I'm so you and I pass by
yeah and now you want to take a meeting
dog [ __ ] that dog I saw you [ __ ] black
people
I will single meeting with you now I got
something to work with buddy know
there's famous stories of Freddy Soto
beam with a manager or an agent and they
[ __ ] him because someone called the
sign like wanted him and
francisco to do show and the agents I
got is own agents like you don't need
that dude we got Carlos Mencia dude you
want Carlos who come and kill you're
like that's your orders a manager here
you know your own [ __ ] food man be
big back in the day what do you got
these coaster the breath tier IV friend
drop names but always like I know that I
taken with everybody when I was in the
top six you know don't just wait it out
and then when I want I was had a meeting
one time and people were like hot sauce
hot sauce
you know I'm a PA wants to have a
meeting and I'm thinking to myself I'll
just letting it flow well it happens you
know but I never signed officially with
a PA but I would with a PA but then my
Asia from a PA got fired or they want to
work with him that's the worst
I'm gonna work with other side huh the
busier Spain or you have like a deal
with a network and you're like it's all
go and then all of a sudden the
president gets fired and it's regime
change and you're like I've seen so many
great ideas like my show on Spike TV ten
years ago but we had we were getting
like some [ __ ] best ratings on the
network regime choice it was called wild
world of spike and it was like Mary was
so crazy ass [ __ ] yeah I didn't even
know I was gonna do that [ __ ] they're
just like you want TV show Mike yeah and
they're like a jackass [ __ ] dogs yeah I
didn't even I was so bad I hate it it's
[ __ ] a bad one time to write I [ __ ]
my back up I learned what Ikea Missoula
is you know the hematoma that's we're
like it's a bruise it's a bruise much my
god bruise it like it like it looks like
you're the AH what is that one Arnold
Schwarzenegger movie with the resistance
where the guy comes out of your gut
whatever that yeah it looks like [ __ ]
just giant thing coming out of wherever
happens do it yeah I got one but I
wasn't on TV show yeah off a ladder
yeah the better reassured by the women
were later fat dog huge one dip in one
for [ __ ] Africa male right I'm from
upstate New York a lien or Armenian I'm
Italian and I mean you know that
call Armenian okay that's cool I'm half
dude I'm half false and it's like I
don't fit in the either world actually
like I'm that's why my own dude you know
and it's just like when I moved out here
everyone's like why you claiming Armenia
I'm like because all the Italians are
like I said I should lose on y'all you
know it's like so Guido
but the Armos are just they're they're
their own things - they always want me
to do their shows it's just like dude
man I'm not that dude I'm a weird guy
you know I just I love it though I love
it so you know you're looking for New
York I thought if I'm endo or something
you're from the east coast
yeah upstate New York - south side of
Syracuse which is so [ __ ] redneck I
didn't realize it till I left and I look
back at my life and like I realized like
I used to be like being a breakdancing
group where everybody had mullets dude
we all had long [ __ ] mullets of them
we were sponsored by the Holiday Inn we
get tracks into a Holiday Inn on him
dude like Kenny Powers - yeah 100% - you
know and it was like so redneck and I
didn't realize that till I left I went
west coast and I went back I'm like
these guys a [ __ ] hex man man they're
everywhere like [ __ ] more focus from the
movie deliverance huh yeah they did it
this country is pretty redneck man it's
pretty [ __ ] hick bro you go up north
blast all the way to the Midwest to the
[ __ ] south dude
and even like can't even like New York
State is like way more redneck than
people think everyone when you say New
York you think New York yeah right
that's that's a whole thing that's its
own thing i Berliner country I'd the
rest of state is just heck dude I know
man and we went to the Poconos to the
other that's Comic Standing to it
well we were done [ __ ] Mountain Brook
Sylvania no no no you New York somewhere
we went to a place where everybody that
was I used to go there and perform and
the 50 thought yeah equiptment yeah all
the beds were hearts yeah yeah and I
adult cam people I don't like being in
one of the places where they shot up so
I'm [ __ ] of dirty dancing
those type of places yeah yeah yeah
whole resort for your whole family
yeah let's cool 70s town and man those
are people there
that they belong in the South but they
saw me they totally rocky really yeah
dude it's hick bro it's crazy
did the people people think that New
York is just all that New York City is
not man
there's boroughs and this new jersey the
dice man
what's that the die sign said anybody
between LA and New York is a farm yeah
it's true it's true man you go someplace
you're like goddamn it's 1985 here man
I said please tell the funny stop and
it's a wonderful club my friend Pete
owns it but next to it you know there's
always like there's a club and it
crosses the bar like if you do a scale
improv there's always the bar next to it
and so next to this bar is what it's
like it looks like a 90s it looks like
something from [ __ ] stranger things
it's like this [ __ ] night late 70s
early 80s [ __ ] dive bar I like do
time stop still like you go around
people are so wearing the Jennifer
Aniston haircut and the the
sunday-school starter pants yeah
variegated gentrification it's very
weird dude it's very weird time just
stops I'm going to a passel and doing a
gig over there with um Oh Paso Mexicans
people they were wearing in 1999-2000
wasn't even doing comments in 1995 but
the first time mom that's 95 huh
96 but I'm struggling you know up and
down that's somebody pregnant quit for
you and have nobody noticed what
happened to you got locked up not back
haha on tour I was on tour it would be
talking like chewy Mexican for my El
Paso like those type of Mexicans yeah
man and they were still wearing um they
were still wearing that [ __ ] Tommy
fingers fingers
Tommy Pilger ahead Hilfiger Tommy
Hilfiger cool bro I did guys say let me
go change shirts and all he did was go
to his house and put on a Tommy Hilfiger
said go to the club see look to the club
so there's a big difference I saw a
video one time it was like the
difference between California Mexican
and Texas Mexican is there a big
difference yeah because those are in
Texas first of all those Mexicans
tex-mex right there more Texas that they
are Mexico they're Lone Star Mexicans
Lone Star but it's like now you see more
like Mexicans like us that are like
speak Spanish and then let parents came
from Mexico opposed to before they're
like in the 90s over more levels like
fool Bruce kaboom yeah before I was
recording all of them
my first timer Texas I saw this Mexican
guy he was not a Mexican guy he was at a
Hondo a section and I thought this fool
did not speak [ __ ] English
yeah I know I don't know he speak
[ __ ] English right so I spoke to the
[ __ ] in Spanish they were like
in LA in California sorry man but I
thought you'd be a home depot and I
looking for work but instead I share
home owners of work you don't know who
he wrote a business he got very offended
amen
Costello this iRiver Wampus a telomere
Padayappa yarn instead Donita
hey man up for Texas week now we are so
pissed off offended in [ __ ] offended
Republic is that Greg in there is that
big in the Latino care the Mexican
community like the difference between
like first or second generation and low
yeah yeah still a Mexican oh yeah man
actually implies higher stylized you get
Latino some Mexican want
third-generation 15-round what are you
[ __ ] tequila now bro now but I'm um I
almost say that my son will be first
generation now your first marriage
because you been here secured a kid yeah
whoo we're doing I don't have negative
you know how affordable customs are you
grew your first generation he's second
generation
I'm from a technically [ __ ] I got us
probably I didn't grow up with like
being in Mexico like you didn't you know
you didn't go back to go take the
Bethesda parallel you didn't [ __ ]
free coke on the back maybe you might
seen if you left Mexico is a blur for
you grew up in LA
oh yeah man like when I when I peak when
I speak Spanish I think about it in
English further than a translator in
like a little time delay has no
confidence I needed right Cuban English
yeah there's no cell or speak fluent
Chinese my big
don't worry Road I'm for because man I
was thinking saw with public Rd dog haha
dude how we cover this was an enemy bro
making him laugh is that what you always
wanted to do now brother travel but at
one time I have dreams met when I'm on
stage man I can't talk
you had a dream I did you want you're
late to a gig I did a gig once when I
first started in Vegas with a buddy of
mine named Mark Achille and he had the
worst stage fright so we needed a tail
in contest he we were given seven
minutes on stage I go up I'm just filthy
I mean like as dirty as I am now I was
dirty back then but that's when
everybody's working you want to go to do
it I'm do my thing the old people like
you know and I get off and they invite
my friend Mark on stage and dude
for seven minutes he just freezes and
he's just breathing into the microphone
shoot this hold a baby good so seven
minutes so they give him the tumor light
and he's like already like it even
thought the whole time dude I was funny
man the hotel bullet did and he cooler
clothes with Luke I'm your father
pontificating yeah you started in Vegas
I started comedy in Las Vegas and we're
at Four Queens nobody you know I uh
those are the rules when I started they
did let local comics go up it stuff of
those that's probably a hardcore
exclusive of their only professional
comedian well because they'd fly all
these uh their openers out from Las
Vegas now I mean out from Los Angeles
now kind of man was doing it so [ __ ]
do a linen you I have the funniest thing
like I had this crazy weekend shine
America mean and I used to live with
Paulo Francisco by the way yeah yeah I
have similar acts yeah yeah yeah Mira's
old in there right you guys go to minke
so I was it I was out there and I get I
get hired to play the acid improv and it
was the last time I played this and then
but I haven't played in years dude so
they fly me out and I get up and a tray
I think was his name with a yes tray
like what increased race great trays
like yeah man we got our best feature
here we want to see how you could do and
I'm thinking to myself why are you
trying to set me up like on your head
like what do you try and that's why I
realized like when you're a comic from
LA and you're doing the circuit in a
weird way like you're like Bruce Lee
you're just going dojo to dojo fighting
everybody's best masters because
everyone's like I could be in LA I
should be in LA they're not that [ __ ]
funny so I go out there and who's
featuring for me is [ __ ] and he's
really nice dude I enjoyed working with
him but I have a crazy Carlos Mencia
story from that [ __ ] time he bumps me
dude Mencia does yeah at the desert
improv Oh
ha ha ha flu outdated to both of you
he was three Highness I am so [ __ ] yeah
dude he used to bump me at the store all
the [ __ ] time he and on the road this
other [ __ ] I see little Brad Williams
waddle in I'm like they said waddle he
knows I love Brian it wasn't his fault
you know he's just trying to get stage
sinuses masters but was his owners um
but when then I saw Carl's come in he
does even shake he shakes my hand buddy
doesn't even look me in the eye those
back of those days would you feel when
he was just like yeah so if you listen
to a mom Marc Maron's podcast you
understand he wanted to teach people
lessons like UD talked about how like
bum people and teach him lessons so then
say those you know he comes up and he
does I had a rule Carlos at that time if
he does anything over 30 minutes
I won't go up because that's a headliner
spot you know yeah start knocking hey
laters but you know if you're doing like
35 that's headliner time you know so I'm
like I tell him if he doesn't mint it
over for a second over 30 I'm not going
up and they go that's totally cool he
does like 28 minutes dude and he is
going from [ __ ] blood homeboy
I mean like you could just tell he is
trying to rip the roof off this place
and put me [ __ ] six feet deep but the
[ __ ] Syracuse's yeah and he goes at the
end egos are all right man it's been my
time place explodes right he did
and then he goes are you ready for your
final comic and collectively the entire
room just goes oh oh like somebody has
to follow this and I got tunnel vision
dude and I'm like I'll [ __ ] that dude
he's me man that dude is me now for the
last like 10 12 years I've been at the
Comedy Store following like dice Joe
Rogan Eddie Griffin like night after
night so I mean I'm skilled but I was
just like odd dude
so I walk up and he does the the worst
thing a comic can do to another comic in
my opinion after stealing jokes the next
thing is he left the stage empty he
[ __ ] introduced me ran off I was
coming this way he ran off that way
so now we're not even like shaky hands
things to let me go up in your show
leaves the [ __ ] stage i go up and i
have this one joke i do that for some
reason always kills at the famous people
i drop it
place explodes i end up killing for 40
[ __ ] minutes to an hour man but he
tried to [ __ ] and bury me dude
the problem is then i go to the bar next
door the [ __ ] piano dueling piano bar
yeah everyone's like they literally go
dude you [ __ ] follow them down
[ __ ] great like they they were like
we became a team right and they're just
buying me shots which i'm blackout drunk
by they have a third shell a [ __ ] i
don't even remember them ever your third
shelter like be ready for next i'm like
watching like 11:30 midnight show pull
off that molinos break it is 7:30
Lillard god damn dude I just did the Sun
say loose funny bone and they're like
yeah we got three shows out I'm like
three shows to greatly ever play it's a
[ __ ] wonderful Club man but three
shows I'm just a stage [ __ ] and I love
it I'll just gig up any time I could do
stamp book man
I'm blackout drunk at this [ __ ] final
show dude and okay guys if you up again
what he's a gone through you think it's
not he'll be a rebel Texas tornado yeah
those crazy dude damn dude so what
happened with China mando Senate well
that was over with China he would you he
had great sets of sound effects and all
he did great man
it was he did [ __ ] great he had fun
he was like had his girlfriend they had
a girl he was having a threesomes with
and they showed up and it was a poor dog
I like dude I had a great idea so it was
so funny traits trying to tell me is
like we're sending our best at you I'm
like why like what is this about like
it's not good for anybody
you trying to bury me here la [ __ ] vodka
company was just showed up and just did
like 20 a 28 yeah that's a record I
didn't heard of that one I thought it'll
go on for the marathon it so I come he
just showed up like hey but what it
shows up hoppiness
but back then that's probably when he
was at its highest in right now actually
that I'm looking before that was when it
was starting to go downhill okay after
the show it was after the the Joe Rogan
snuff tape thing okay and then it gets
[ __ ] aha then it got weird you know
and I know I guess he's going around
doing apologies for our Redemption tour
yeah called well that's what he's
[ __ ] to say on the Joey Diaz podcast
[ __ ] not to make a man's and [ __ ] you
have done those out David Tribble runs I
never did a terma one me neither
I want Tripoli on the Tribble run no
I'll do but I've had so many [ __ ] gigs
dude as a Tripoli rubber I just double
is beauty comes a lot dude I can't you
see how happy I am and how how awesome
it is that I think how have you blown up
92 so [ __ ] fun mission you that the
was I made a man here yeah because I
know what time I showed up at Dublin's
and you were never trying to get up and
I got up and then I just did it I feel
like ten minutes but it was good that
you sit down bro you up to like a rock
star status
yeah I shouldn't leave here this place
okay so there's gonna happen tonight
oh you're killer man I feel like II just
I you know some funny is when you are
last kind of [ __ ] I go he's gonna win
that I knew you're gonna win when I did
and it just [ __ ] be on dude and I
love it it's blown up and he did you're
working what you work to a clod on your
[ __ ] hbl thing he's a good friend of
mine I think it's [ __ ] Commons
Without Borders together yeah oh dude
can I tell that story so
I'm friends with Russell Peters and
Scott Montoya and Scott was really cool
and Scott's like Triple E I'm trying to
get you in to this thing but there's not
enough budget I'm working on it so he
comes like Russell's really cool he's
giving up his clothes budget we're gonna
get you in the show I'm like dude that's
[ __ ] great so I show up and they're
like okay so everybody is it was like
all my friends are headlight and then
they have these openers who now are
wonderful comics but they are they all
just started at this point so these guys
are all getting like [ __ ] softball
pitches to follow I walk up and they're
like yeah you're going on after Felipe
I'm like why do I have to follow Felipe
right so it was like this so Felipe's on
stage and the best way described it is
when Vaughn Dom is in bloodsport you
ever met her blood yeah and he's just
all over your boom-boom he's like what
the [ __ ] is a boom-boom and he walks
around a lookout and Tom Poe is just
[ __ ] hitting this the [ __ ]
cinderblock al-kamil boom boom boom and
he's like what the [ __ ] is this that's
how I felt when I was listen to Felipe
up there [ __ ] murder this [ __ ]
room just a [ __ ] room is shaking I'm
like what the [ __ ] is going up I'm like
why do I have to be the guy who follows
him dude so luckily I had done stand-up
for a long time and I had what a good
set based on the comments on our video I
bought what is my view it was [ __ ] ID
to father [ __ ] the dude you should
easily put the one closing it that night
but I had to follow you it was like that
you I always talk about I've had to
follow to the hardest comics ever the
following comedy I've evolved Felipe
Esparza at the comics well borders and
then I had to follow [ __ ] Katt
Williams at the [ __ ] chocolate
sundaes live in the Sunset Strip and
just like that time your time I had done
stand-up on TV for a while and I've gone
to Montreal and Bob
cuz I tapped into something for my
audition that I didn't know how to do so
they brought me up and they made me
follow Corey Holcomb man who like I know
how old is Corey Hawkins they were know
I like this was 20 years ago and he was
a 20-year vet then see guys like first
towards old man some good a genetics
player yeah you know how we do did to
God does now I can find no problem but
back then I heat across I didn't know
what the [ __ ] to do and I went there and
I bombed anyway so I'm on this
Redemption tour and I just got to show
everybody and Pookie's like hey Sam you
want to do chocolate sundaes I'm like
[ __ ] yeah I show up Who am I following
cab Bucky Williams flamethrower and I
had a [ __ ] great set I just it's like
I get thrown in the purple situation and
somehow survivor follow you was the
hardest thing I've had to do like live
I'm like why am i doing it's live I laid
first [ __ ] Showtime but it ended up
going fine you crushed so hard that that
[ __ ] I like myself I was back there
man I can't believe I follow the rules
and and I went with what they told me to
wear to other things why would I like
well I like gray shirt bro all sweating
like a beast and you were shiny I don't
know what to wear that or wear these
clothes I wish I understand a man under
people don't look good on me if you
choose your clothes with that style
I I usually only do suits on stage I
used to do suits all time now I just
sweat too much so I just I like to wear
nice but I used I haven't done
television I've kind of just made my
whole [ __ ] off the internet now my shoe
my own special put it out as a name your
price and then just work out see if I
can get any traction so always always
missed it there right yeah you shutters
on went through with iPhone yeah I do
crazy seven different size oh I've been
seen it by here it's amazing is this
your first special I have three albums
out my last my last album called the
diabolical the two disc CD that I just
put out it's available on iTunes in the
first hours called the diabolical and it
Spacely stories the second hour is
called Friday night Late Show and it's
just me eating a dog
stick in front of this [ __ ] really
shitty ass [ __ ] Sacramento punchline
Late Show Friday crowd and that's one of
my favorite clubs but these are drunk
and sloppy and about five minutes and I
realize this is not a crowd you want to
record so then for the next 40 minutes I
just start ripping everybody new [ __ ]
so for the price of all one city you get
to this will be my first yeah my first
hour how long video
you started the original dirty show huh
started to not there was the headline
show the necklace belladonna yeah
belladonna on the doors and [ __ ] that
[ __ ] was tight over I did that show bro
belladonna had went about to follow her
dog and what'd she do how were you in
that sure we also yes do what I say to
follow her man and see how you follow
that hope you like it you gotta lick
this pole dude our that moment pretty
man without makeup and all that so
another show should have been on
television yeah reason it never happened
I just it was this weird moment where
Hollywood wanted female comedy or nerd
comedy and it didn't fit in but I'm
still do I'm gonna bring it back I'm
going to bring it back maybe do it in
long beach at harvelle's but you know
the problem with that shows I let people
define as a porns show and it wasn't a
Porsche those were just small parts of a
bigger [ __ ] thing the thing that
happened with there is that we got
belladonna to do it and like porn stars
are like comedians like you know what
economy so everybody wants to beat the
store now because that's where all the
names are all the porn star saw
belladonna was do my show all of a
sudden they all wanted to do the show
because it was a status thing you know
but when she deep throat I remember I
was standing next to Moshe kasher and
she takes us like 12-inch black dog and
she's pole dancing and she just goes
bow puts in her mouth pole dances for it
and the room is quiet nobody says
anything they're just like what the [ __ ]
and as soon as she stopped the place
just you know was like remember that
Michael Jordan commercial where he goes
in slow-mo like that's what happened I
was just like oh and boom or suits yet
then the place exploded I'm like that's
what you want because when I started a
naughty shell
I want a place to do dirty comedy and
when it started like there was nowhere
like everybody still want clean like now
it's like you could do you you be you
it's almost like push the envelope but
then it wasn't like that at all so I
said if I put porn stars on the show the
people don't like dirty comedy probably
won't show up either I use them as kind
of a repellant from people who hate fun
you know so oh we put up we give out all
these sponsors on this weed and then we
move to the Comedy Store and it's great
had a five-year run but after a while
you're like okay I'm editing a prank I'm
about to bring the another short do a
sound Tripoli was at their old strip bar
that turned into a regular room that's
the Safari Safari Sam's bro if we had a
[ __ ] burlesque show how many shows
have you done yeah we're support so I
like the burlesque show though potential
is very very out there I think on any
input on the show everybody we're all
dressed up by the way everybody was
dressed up I was wearing a suit Lisa
wearing a very beautiful dress the host
is full of Cory look like a Don yeah and
this will have like real real burlesque
show and he had a weird guy that was
doing prints a blew everybody away yeah
awesome show - yeah a little bit of TV
they should have been on television but
you know it's weird now now it's like
everything's [ __ ] edgy and dirty now
so we'll see what happens I just love
doing it it's a fun show and it's a
crazy show but now I got this new show
called comedy chaos at the Comedy Store
do you want to my favorite show I've
ever done and I'm bringing it back in
July it's called The Rock and pol World
Championships of rock and pull rock and
pull World Championship and space is
where I take a singer and I team them up
with a pole dancer and they become a
team and you remember that old
Whitesnake video where it's like here
I'll go get on my own and tie containers
just grinding on the car it's like that
it's like teams and it's like a singing
dancing competition and it is the
greatest show you'll ever see in your
[ __ ] life dude it's because it's
every song you love and it's like great
pole dancing and it's choreography and
the place explodes that we've done that
Viper Room a bunch of times and we're
going to bring it back we're going to
streamit though and I'm excited too it's
a fun show I'm going to try to get that
on television too but the others I'm
just what I do it hasn't a pull those
things there they're team a singer and a
dance together why the guy sings a girl
does choreography on the pole and people
go [ __ ] nuts
it's the we set New Year's Eve drinking
numbers when we do this show because
people come lose everyone's probably
doing blow and it's just a great [ __ ]
I just love to rock you know I just when
you had that show littles another fool
man he put me in the show then I fourth
start doing poor and broke dan o silver
oh yeah
he wouldn't put me on the show he was in
a band order to wear jolted Robbie Skid
Row and now who's to lead the singer
Skid Row Aaron do you remember he's
white sebastian vettel wrong we'll do a
show on one under under dating he wasn't
tore him bro which were pretty much
winter so this'll only be December
November then who disappeared won't come
back again till December November due to
other shows he lives in Vegas now I
think he's doing stuff I did a porn in
RV but I saw it I think he's also into
the swingin community now like about oh
I don't want to be in a swinger bar next
to a guy with the darkest hair there you
know it's fake you know it's so funny
it's like I've done shared a naughty
show during AVN's and we did it at this
famous swingers club with all of it the
green door and it's in Vegas is famous
one and it's like we put the tickets on
sale it sells out three 350 in like
literally an hour tickets gone we show
up we do stand-up it's [ __ ] great and
everyone's hanging out dude and it just
swears clubs is just black guys with
dreads making love to big polar bears
just big white chicks and it's everyone
just sits around and [ __ ] watches it
and it's freaking hilarious now we go
swingers club usually swingers are
nudists are it's more like a warning
like hey I'm about to get naked watch
yourself but I go to Canada
and dude they probably do swingers club
just because I'm in
- Oh guys - they're like hey dude let's
bring to the spring to swing huh I'm
like I don't really need to go but okay
let's go
everybody's good looking it's the first
time I've never been to a swingers club
everybody's attractive I went to a
swingers club with Darren Carter bro oh
my god Arizona bagging party star ready
attack school well I thought I told um
Eric Rick Ingram and Eleanor Kerrigan
The Comedy Store podcast but that fool
like definitely go change dog and he
came back wearing Richard Simmons shorts
and eating skittles grossed out right
there oh wow didn't Aaron Carter brother
went red the little red Richard Simmons
shorts with a little night nylon little
underwear Nicola are you telling me he
got it is like superhero swingers cam
and yes and tube socks bro do you think
he does swinging I have no idea bro
laughter two years ago yeah laughter -
oh we get there blonde hair then and
don't read here but here is hearing it
lately like there's a bunch of red ants
crawling on yeah but Hector is 35 bucks
to get in each so we all paid ha ha and
there's like five guys standing up
inside of a Jacuzzi ready to go that
lady like at least 48 back then blowing
all of them bro
and they're like rubbing her head or
grabbing a little saggy titties but tell
you the one of those best trip one of
the best ever swingers club ever bro
they had a buffet ha ha ha hey there's a
fat lady there wearing an idea you don't
want her to wear an ID bro chill a honey
Boo Boo's mom and she was by 41 I
actually have a vagina you're always in
the game it was called encounters place
and it I didn't know that by Phoenix
have ain't got winters bars there's two
of them and there's a lot of em
encounters and chances chances there's a
magazine dedicated or swingers bar I
don't even know the communities
Illustrated yeah bro bring your lady set
encounter swingers joke ever heard
within a movie man it was that guy that
caught masturbating in Hollywood what's
it name
Polly Herman not probably Reuben he does
a street of against movies oh oh yeah
Fred
Fred Willard ah you know I'm not so bad
for that doing like an old guy doesn't
right away so lady [ __ ] won't leave
the house we can't your cost so he go
somewhere and what okay what kind of
person are you when you get [ __ ] put
on old man jerk-off vice patrol like you
got to go down to the pet and theater
and [ __ ] make sure all dudes aren't
beating off in theatres I mean what what
kind of human being are you imagine
being you join the force because you
want to [ __ ] make the world a safer
place and they put you on beat off
Patrol I know slipper the first pain I
live a fabric of go that far bro beat
off in a movie theater but I think I've
been teleported plane
I wasn't it my girlfriend wouldn't leave
the house sometimes I went down to a
porn theater and I was in the booth and
one of my friends came up on the videos
it was very uncomfortable
I was like yeah Darrow Doug I saw a porn
video bro does a comedian without a -
bro
where is that who the one that steamed
bbbbb w chick was put on a porno with
him yeah I don't know we had him on a
pocket we had Diaz Mackey
Hollywood's pay majors came ha ha ha he
has Mackey 100% I heard two other
comedians have been on pornos but it
wasn't those fools which one well I
heard it there's a dude I was hanging
out the whole once and add 100 was it
though yeah man it's weird
I seen Larry Omaha on a [ __ ] in the
porn no but not doing pornography like
it's an extra like as a bartender or
something like in a song or four ha ha
remember hands the bag vouchers for that
I don't know whoa
and I remember like throwing a handful
like he was like anyone like I could
officially over having proper deal so it
wasn't like he was gonna start other
videos like I actually have catering on
sets I used to have a great joke about
because I would this one point you as
guy was walking around with catering and
I'm like this guy so this guy's making
pigs in the blanket on a set of pigs in
a plain cake you know
double entendre that is funny man
[ __ ] nuts even about in the porn
industry then I've never done it so you
know TT boy see people I don't know TT
for her boys dogmatic pity the poor
start oh yeah that fool was too [ __ ]
Coppola her galedog every portal we
believe uh I took the only time I choked
on a laugh bro
chichi boy brought over to CT horrible
oh hell no he's a good-looking guy he's
pretty shredded yeah
TT boy sounds like a [ __ ] you know he
was just a porn star man he's done I
think he was dating a Wednesday from
Addams Family that's how far he goes
back when zip of an original Addams
Family ah really
Christina Ricci and always don't know
one black and Wow my gosh I'm gonna be a
old-ass lady now behind the green door
so you've been to the behind the green
door the green door I received a movie
behind the green door with marilyn
Chambers never all right have you seen
Godfather - yeah okay I got for the -
when I'm doing during Cuba they're
watching a Superman porn show yeah you
read the book write her better night uh
yeah yeah I'm on another kid I want
another turn and they talked about going
to Cuba and there's a sex scene and from
Blackfoot shows up with a massive tia
carrere oh wow
well you know that the true story right
now well watching go for the - right and
the black guy in the sexy comes out of a
out of a green curtain like a black
green curtain so now I'm thinking get
the Chamber brother milk that the
[ __ ] brothers who made a porn robbery
lit from Japan idea of course novel
because in um in uh in the behind the
green door the same brother comes out of
the green door with a cape and a big
dick and he [ __ ] 20 year-old measuring
chambers in the movie on the mall in a
[ __ ] in Miami and then when they're
cut off father - in Cuba if they bring
out that chick and he has sex with her
in the same way I'm thinking they stole
the idea I mean it took that was a big
old famous show
back in the days when the Mafia's world
there yeah I mean I'm sure it's a porn
parody at that point right yes I wonder
if the green door it in Vegas was around
they just baked without that yet another
the green door also in San Francisco
Maryland's porn was just so simple back
then yeah it's like we're hard to find
huh
yeah the old ones yeah dude now it's
just like stunt [ __ ] you're like dude
people are dying felonies being
committed here this is too much I know
this like 20 euros do we buy a group or
you don't need a dog save it for me
yeah poor fluffers they're out of
business now yeah replaced by viagra no
fruit about it yeah what kind of porn do
you like to watch with your lady when
you guys are making love the engineer
yeah huh he loves to make love to his
lady my list I'll watch one time does a
little duck I remember what to into a
story about to change robbing you yeah
it's a to so happen so hot at least yeah
they're people George Costanza on you
you know what's so funny as I was at the
saddle ranch right there you know it's
trouble yeah yeah this is your hot room
too bro Monday nights well that's the
one in a reversal City how did stand up
at the one a Hollywood oh I tell
Universal Studios yeah yeah yeah the one
to Hollywood is where I was hanging out
and I just started you know this is
young Triple E like like early 20s
Tripoli not like [ __ ] breakdancers
Tripoli right and Tripoli and I am I was
there and I just was talking to all this
Australian guy for into some reason we
were just talking and hey might yeah
alright and like you ever been to
Australia ever done stand-up never it's
[ __ ] phenomenal but like everything so
expensive there because you have to ship
it there so like even their booze is
expensive everything so like you do a
shot it's literally a symbol it's like
there's not a lot of you know it's
expensive as [ __ ] so they come over here
and they order a shot and it's like a
[ __ ] bucket you know so that I'm
doing shots with this Australian when
these three girls come up and start
talking to us and we
you know we're just doing shots and
talking [ __ ] and I'm like hey you want
to go back to my place I'm like yeah
they're like yeah so I grabbed this
Australian I don't even know why throw
over in my car
the girls follow me back to my place and
I get the cute one and we're starting to
fool around right I'll know wherever
these girls just grab here we got go by
grab the girls and run out and I
literally chase them with my pull my
pants up going what the [ __ ] going on
I called the Australian dude is passed
out he's blacked out passed out gone
couldn't hang with the Americans right
gone the girls jump in their car driver
I come out they sold a [ __ ] of water
cash a bunch of [ __ ] CDs because this
was at the time and a bunch of [ __ ]
Xbox games because we her friends play
xbox just jacked them all dude ran off
with them stole it did ran a [ __ ] ski
mommy do you have the cute one [ __ ]
fool around me why they just go through
all my [ __ ] and it's just like I'm like
I go to Australia god damn you're
supposed to watch everything he's like
no I was just sucking out the whole time
the [ __ ] out of here
far dam will they put a fast one on you
Holly oh chicks or something or what
Hollywood hairstylist you put a puzzle
on a tree - whoo hello oh my god
[Laughter]
do you ever do old bits yeah man what up
what I [ __ ] I know the clothes not
paying attention I rescue lover
punchline Alanna Thursday show and I
feel 35 people there they're getting the
worst comedy ever whoa I feel bad like
you know I hang out Rogan and I love
Rogan and Joe Rogan's he's always like
new material new booty and I feel bad
when I do old jokes but I have some
classics like the other night out of
nowhere I just pulled out like a 20 year
old bit like 21 22 year-old bit and it
crushed and I was like like a nobody and
probably is listen to my first CD I
think about if it's not on tape on
Showtime and running on Netflix or the
whole thing that on YouTube you could
you get to do it over
like what if it sound like an old album
like an old old album I would do it man
it's your material dude I mean I would
do it before somebody meeting to a meal
ha ha ha
I've been thinking about just going
through my I put out three albums taking
the best ones and just adding them to
like I have a new like I just put out my
album like a like three months ago
and I have a new like 3540 but I want to
make it a murder hour and taking some my
classics that I know you know even
though if you like specially now you you
put a CD out on like iTunes
you're lucky to sell a 100 or 200
because everybody's just Spotify sit now
it's like nobody's buying CDs anymore
it's like you do an hour and you just
throw out the [ __ ] the audio for
[ __ ] free you know just so I'm
thinking about going back getting all
the old good [ __ ] putting it together
and trying to put out this killer hour I
have this bit about smoking crack that I
didn't do on my last album that I want
to put out and some I mean I just want
to get your guys thoughts on doing old
Joe do it man yeah okay before once
weird ah my first day in Hollywood oh
well I was a big city got robbed to hit
the pipe with my wallet that's not
enough Segundo oh yeah would you like it
didn't you see my brother the only thing
you're thinking when you smoke crack is
I'm smoking crack I'm smoking crack I'm
smoking crack I'm smoking crack I can't
believe I'm smoking crack I can't
believe I'm smoking crack this dude try
to suck my dick so I punched him and I
[ __ ] ran off happened rule happen it
happens when you punch that will happen
they're you know they're you know chase
around [ __ ] really dog people get weird
stuff over the hug wish no the guy was a
pro the bottle it had a couple cake
Oh [ __ ] a man I'm wearin out the rehab
there was a guy that he goes listen man
time we're badi I said come on Melanie
knit knit knit or tell me we're down on
somebody right away because they're not
now man funny guys do it it [ __ ] yeah
cuz you know they're like they're
smoking me out haha and the guy was just
blow me solo
[ __ ] Katie [ __ ] I'm originally crack a
case it worked it [ __ ] they could
really good hi how do you party anymore
anymore my sub party in 2009 I just move
we butts out drinking you don't drink
anymore cuz you get [ __ ] up yeah
you're look at party Hulk in Burbank now
nobody goes because I'm only me and your
to know about it and another comedian
now the one it passed away in Las Vegas
who oh ah brother da da da g JP JP Katie
that was so sad that was so sad looking
horrible though goes to try to save
people nobody helps them and they kill
them like Joey Diaz always says just
mind your business
I have you say people's lives man and
David that guy was gonna go shoot a
bunch of [ __ ] people and that guy
[ __ ] fought him and nobody came and
helped them it was really sad security
go rat huh brand well blame them how
much you get paid not enough of that
dogs not enough yeah dude I go to bet
you go to Vegas at all haven't been
there in a did though for bees right so
yeah yeah
the trip will be billiards brewing
something oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
with all what's-his-face Carlos big free
Big Daddy Carlos having said yeah you
know that fool I did shows out there
yeah yeah Big Daddy card will he's a
character man he wife yeah they own the
velvet margarita out here it's wonderful
yeah they were telling me that they're
gonna have a big old fundraiser for
something and the or me to come red
carpet event you know that guy when we
met him that when he was a character ha
looking like professional football
players I don't know they had a [ __ ]
cowboy hat on yeah sunglasses he's a
great dude dude he's a given lady party
to party hard order still part of where
I party where people are party hard they
were watching I love Vegas then what's
the craziest party that you're a bid to
it since you've been in Hollywood like
20 20 year old separately but you did
say crazy spy me I use not your own oh
yeah like tell us after naughty show
everybody everybody there there I know
there's [ __ ] mm [ __ ] doublings was
nuts celebrities and [ __ ]
are you see either absolutely nily or
bomb ah one time there was a like his
honesty I know huh so we were gonna
admit it broke know everywhere look they
come over here we talk to them off to
off the podcast they never talk about it
we had great great set always tore it up
always to it up always gonna do up in
this yeah they then came up to me
talking about a mercy nothing like this
it's people came out to me I said you're
undeniable no dude it's very rare now
that I bomb I've weird sets I have some
weird sets welcome to the club you know
I don't think you ever having even close
to a bad set i I think I die internally
bro I should inside man with the haha at
the same way last week this Joe ended up
long break
I've told all Ian says that this joke
killed in the hood but you I every time
I see you it's like anihilation I'm
trying to do some tests
sorry guys that's the hardest thing
about LA now it's just like it's so hard
to find place to do new job yeah man
it's I'm trying to start this new room
just for new jokes or guys can go and
just do new material not to worry about
you know because like the lineups at the
economy so it's all murder fest so like
Pablo Francisco a long time ago said to
me you don't do new jokes T improv so I
don't ever do new jokes The Improv
unless it I know it's a killer new joke
that the comedy story that's why you
should work [ __ ] out and now it's not
like that they have
miss people all the way up to midnight
now and you know the last factories here
there it's I like that place but it's
like where you do your new material I do
my new material on Sundays at the where
I'm at like by working at the punchline
I'm not working there at the Lana
punchline I deliver new material on
Sunday show and a Thursday show but like
now that I did my tape my one-hour
special September 30 on HBO
um the contract stays I can't do those
jokes anywhere no more what I can't do
our I can't perform a live shows ask
ever a to release I can't do it at
school so I've been man I been
struggling bro but I like it though cuz
my she's darker now dawg well do you
verse right to go where you want to go
now I could do I could go I learn the
right now now if I want to talk about my
brother coming out I could do talking
about my brother coming out of prison
worst at the born-again Christian you do
that job without game I'm the microphone
ask away from me he have skills our
confidence to tell a new jodan before
you you've created your own market and
it's like you know it's like I just I
just did a little work with Doug Sano if
I got to pop in on his uh Sara Kishore I
had lined up sir his funny bone and then
he let me pop in for tell quick my
crack-smoking story in his show but do
you watch a show he'll even tell you his
crowds come for blood and they wanted to
go [ __ ] weird you know it's like
these are your crowds yeah you're
filling the room you should be able to
go up there go poor people people banned
for [ __ ] an hour if you [ __ ] you want
to because it's your [ __ ] crowd you
should be able to take a [ __ ] on the
stage set on fire as long as it sells
out and they buy two drinks the club
should never say anything so you could
get as dark as you want to it's your
[ __ ] thing man that's the beauty of
making it we're black face dark blue
yeah we're so full what's your Twitter
Instagram Google follow you at Sam
Tripoli TR IPO our life Sam Tripoli
I have all the instagrams and I have a
YouTube page now I'm really working on
my youtube channel youtube.com slash Sam
Tripoli PRI pol I I put up something
every day I put up on my podcast and
check out the diabolical man two days
for the price of one storytelling I tell
about getting off being on the run from
a police helicopter and getting away I
got away dude and so here I got a once
thought over here does 100% of the true
story and Tripoli oh the run geez yeah
all this crazy [ __ ] so check it out man
it went to number one on eye to eye to
albums went to number one and your song
exchange you didn't pay for this yeah
all right want to make sure yeah
so what elbows I'll tell ya it should we
send you a check because when you stop
myself it on Spotify when they put on
Pandora when some idiot decide to play
on a radio without asking me I get money
yeah
sound good good to publish Spotify
shit's not met they have to change it
dude because Spotify is meant for music
I mean if I like Felipe's jams I might
listen that over and over and over again
right everybody but a joke but like you
listen to it once maybe twice and you
can pay the same as a song which is a
completely horrible way of paying like
it they should pay more for jokes doing
working on that right aren't they have
example I made it up well we're gonna be
able to every once I watch 17th through
the 24th this month at a V theater and
Planet Hollywood in Vegas with it well
that's great
what do you start going there Monday
Monday next Monday I love that one for
seven days and then we're going to come
back to do a show at the brain prov on
the 20th that's right back and drive
back that night and she was gonna be
there dog what and we're not gonna have
a podcast they went you know go out on
Friday Friday morning okay Friday night
I'm at the ice house tonight when this
comes out i'm with jim Florentine at the
ice house then I have a I want you guys
to do with the 25th at the Comedy Store
if you can it's comedy chaos I already
have a [ __ ] murder lineup I love for
you guys be part of it and
and I am at Toronto I'm at the comedy
corner - 26 27 28 29 so come out and see
me
is that a comedy corner with a guy
Georgia cheeto yeah Joe he's cool bro I
love Toronto it's my idea
eternal jiggle when I want to go do that
good show at the underground cafe yeah
you see they have Boggs right
all the people have bond you walk outs
like gorillas in the mist you just see
[ __ ] dark ship moving in the [ __ ]
smoke puffs bomber selling [ __ ] weed
brought it on the side damn it was good
good stuff there bro I'm head oh man I
thought I drew picked me up
he had [ __ ] 5 5 blah sorry rolled up
broke it he goes it'll heal up man
either for you and then he lived one
over here's brought I'm gonna you know
something to give you five blunts
and you didn't like one of yours up nah
man he did is up gave me my five foot
Restless yeah
Canada has maximum so on the way into
this gig in 10th grade coke I don't do
it anymore but it is great on the way
here to this up yeah I'll be surprised
oh no I got you you're like how far do
they got put this poor guy has he come
with coke in his ass all the way up to
[ __ ] Canada but dude I know the spot
for all that [ __ ] all do what because it
will you York by boat and then going to
Toronto okay eventually gets tip on
Florida or Texas and to be stepped on
then other times I'll did allies got the
worst copy go that's a big reason I
tried town Detroit and then there too
that's a big reason I wasn't the
building that down in the nineties oh
well anyways we got a couple of shout
outs people okay man no podcast for the
next two weeks until further notice you
never know my my bus apart Keller corpus
am I put it out there but they're gonna
be the sound quality it won't be good
old braver than an engineer what are
some fool shoutouts to biker eighty who
gave us a good iTunes review he listens
in the kitchen while he cooks his he's a
vegan chef for the LA archdiocese it's
not a couple of preacher or vegan this
weekend July 13 to the 15 Corpus Christi
Texas at mesquite Street Mesquite skeet
mesquite Street comedy club next week in
July
22 23rd of bein Tampa Florida at the
temple improv hit me up at fans as
pelipper's WorldCom for free ticket to
Tampa improper only Tampa only Tampa
July 27 through 29 in Des Moines Iowa
just added July 25th of 2016 munch we
are just for Laughs festival August
during 5th at 11:00 a live in Oxnard
all right man that's it oh man you know
people I [ __ ] finally got me a Costco
card bro and I saw the people coming out
of Costco huh ok it looks like bad out
of shape people bro it shouldn't be a
Cosmo a bomb-ass Costco hot dogs halo
there odd for I didn't know that that
man I heard about a pair of t-shirts
when I got it home 6 t-shirts in there
bro I'm just totally two in a pack damn
war so full sound Triple E here in the
house I remember man before you go up
needs to be another comedian bro I hate
you confusing guys in the beginning Sam
Bowie or [ __ ] belt or [ __ ] you know I
don't remember him okay we're splash
that scratch that out were so fool check
on some stripper and iTunes
Instagram check out a show tonight at
the ice house with jim Florentine check
that [ __ ] out by his elbow download that
[ __ ] when you see a man color what's up
[ __ ] sound Tripoli I was hoping to
get a lap dance on one of your comedy
show tonight well make it happen war
several gog gog the concert lounge
riverside california july 26 we have
Annie McKnight there I met a Mitchell
that night so it was cool I love a
matter that we don't have any show no
show next week on the 19th but the 26
were so fool damn it Evan okay check out
my podcast